翻訳: Yuta Kawamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は幼い頃
体力がなく スポーツができず
勉強もできない そんな子供でした
そんな私の最初の夢は
魔法使いになることでした
どうやら あれは嘘らしい
（笑）
で ちょっと泣いた後ですね
私は今度は
ドラえもんを手に入れることを企てました
（笑）
彼のあの ひみつ道具があれば
どんなに楽しいだろう
あの道具があればこんなことができる
（笑）
ところが ほどなくして
また私は知ってしまった
ドラえもんが生まれる22世紀まで
自分がおそらく
生きることができないということ
（笑）
そして その時は
もう本当に泣きました
で ひとしきり泣いた後
思いついたんです
22世紀が待てないのであれば
自分でひみつ道具を作ればいいと
我が家は少し特殊でした
私が父から守らされたのは
人を傷つけないこと
そして人の物を盗まないこと
この２つです
これさえ守っていれば
多少 社会のルールから外れようが
いえ だいぶ社会のルールから外れても
何も言わない そういう親でした
結構とんでもないと思います
（笑）
ただ そんな私は
それに気を良くして
小学校の頃から
やれ図書館に行きたい
やれ秋葉原に行きたいと
学校を休みがちでした
当然 友達なんかできません
人付き合いも分かりませんでした
そんな私を救ってくれたのは
自分が作った いくつかのひみつ道具でした
忍者の履く 水蜘蛛のようなもの
ロケット花火をある時間になると
自動的に発射する装置
（笑）
そんな他愛のないものでした
ただ ある時から周りの人が何人か
実験を手伝ってくれるようになりました
そうやって私は 少しずつ
人との付き合い方を覚えていきました
気を良くした私は
足が遅いのであれば
電気で走るスケボーを
泳げないのであれば
発泡スチロールで船をと
自分自身の努力じゃなく
できないことをできるようにする
ひみつ道具を作ることで
解決を図るようになっていきました
（笑）
そんな子供が そのまま大人になった
それが私です
（笑）
今日は皆さんに
そんな私が仲間と作った
いくつかの秘密道具
ご紹介したいと思います
ある時 私は思いました
あ〜 空を自由に飛びてぇな
（笑）
子供ん時じゃないですよ
だいぶいい年になってからです
（笑）
最初は 例のタケコプターですね
あれみたいに
自分自身を飛ばすことを考えました
ただ 今の技術では
すごい巨大な装置になります
運搬して 組み立てて 動作確認をして
周囲の安全に配慮して 安全点検して
で 最後に運輸局の許可取って
その後やっと飛び立つことができる
なので 私はこう思いました
今 思いたってすぐ飛び立てる
そんな道具が必要だ
そして作ったのが
エクストコプターという道具です
これは 自分自身ではなく
自分の分身を空に飛ばします
映像の奥で
私が立って操縦をしています
このエクストコプター
カメラと２本のアームが付いています
カメラは VRゴーグルを通じて
自分の目となり
アームは自分の動きを計測する
Kinect（キネクト）という装置を使って
自分の腕と同じように動きます
自分の動きを自分の体で行うことで
それをそのまま遠くにあるロボットに
伝えることができる
そういうロボットです
作ってみた結果
わかったことがあります
とても 酔うんです
（笑）
カメラで撮った映像は
微妙な遅れを伴って自分の目に届きます
この数百ミリ秒というわずかな遅れは
私たちに乗り物酔いと同じような
効果を生みます
一種のVR酔いの一つですね
ただ この問題は 科学の技術とともに
徐々に解決されつつあり
2020年には より良いものが作れる
そういうふうに目論んでいます
このドローン 最近何かと悪い方向で
有名にはなってしまいましたが
とても面白くて
高い将来性があることは
間違いありません
そんなドローンを
夜な夜ないじってるとですね
色んなものが作りたくなるんですね
次にこのドローンを使用したひみつ道具
１つお見せします
動画を流しますので
これが一体 何をする道具なのか
当てていただければと思います
一見 普通のドローンなんですが
特徴的なのは この先端に付いてる
もふもふっとしたやつですね
このもふもふ 自由に角度を調整できる
アームの先端に付いています
そしてドリルのように
ぐるぐる回ります
でまた カメラが付いていて
目標物を認識して
自動でゆっくりと近づいていきます
もうちょい もうちょい
はい そろそろお分かりですかね
はい これ 世界初
「洗車をするドローン」です
（笑）
「ぐるる」といいます
で ただですね 皆さん 多分
頭の中にあると思うんですが
「これで洗車するのはバカだろう」と
あまりにも効率が悪すぎます
そこで活躍するのが
この「くるる」という相棒のロボットです
くるるは自動車の表面に張り付いて
表面のホコリをくるくると
ルンバのように落としていきます
車の大体の汚れは 毎日こうやって
継続的にホコリを落とすことで
だいぶ抑えることができます
ただそれだけでは取りきれない
例えば 鳥のフンみたいな汚れがあった時に
このくるるは
先ほどのぐるるに救援要請を出します
ぐるるは 呼ばれると
自分の充電ステーションから飛び立ち
くるるの位置を自動で認識して
洗剤のついたブラシで
局所的な清掃を行う
そういうシステムです
作ってみた結果 これにもですね
たくさんの課題が見つかりました
ここでは挙げません
ただ私の車には
この時についたたくさんの傷が
（笑）
今でも残っています
次にですね
私たちが ドローンと同じぐらい
注力しているひみつ道具
人の移動手段「モビリティ」について
ご紹介したいと思います
自動車をはじめとしたモビリティ
外見上こそ そんなに
大きな変化はないですが
中身はとても新しい技術が
数多く投入されています
そんなモビリティの分野で
新しい使い方や 使われ方
こういったものを提案できるものを
私たちは作っています
トヨタ自動車を育てた豊田英二さんは
こう言ったといいます
「理想の車とは孫悟空が乗る
『筋斗雲』である」と
筋斗雲は雲のような外観を持ち
呼べば 颯爽と現れて
乗れば 自由自在に動き回ることができ
目的地を告げれば 連れてってくれる
そして 決して事故を起こさない
真に受けた私たちは
これを実際に作ってみることにしました
できたの これです
（笑）
「KINTON（キントン）」といいます
残念ながら空は まだ飛びません
特徴的なのはこの外観です
風船でできています
座る人の形状に合わせて
雲のように自由自在に形を変えます
キントンには
カメラとレーザーセンサーがついており
障害物を避けながら
自動的に目的地に向かったり
自分の飼い主を見分けて
後を荷物を持ってついて行ったり
他にも おしゃべりをしたり
嫌いな人が乗ると振り落としたり
（笑）
結構 実用的な機能を盛り込みました
そんな中でもですね
特に 色んな人に喜んでいただけたのは
この機能です
「指さし操縦機能」といいます
キントンは特殊な腕輪型のセンサーを
つけることで操縦をすることができます
その腕輪をつけて 行きたい方向を指差すと
その方向に向かいます
映像で 黒い服の彼が指差した方向に
この子供を乗せたキントンが
向かってってるのが分かると思います
この機能
お年寄りから子供まで
一度体験すれば 誰でも
自由自在に操縦できる
そういう機能になりました
この「誰でも」という点で
このキントン
とても大きな気づきを
私たちに与えてくれました
誰でも乗れるモビリティ
これを考えた時
私たちは無意識のうちに
健常者を対象にしてることに
気がつきました
そこで私たちは その枠を広げて
障がい者の方も乗れる
モビリティにしたい そう思いました
作ったのはこの
「Exo-Wheel（エグゾホイール）」
という車椅子型のモビリティです
世の中には たくさんの車椅子型の
モビリティが提案されています
ただ そのほとんど全てが
障がい者の方のみに
向けて作られています
私たちはそうではなく
障がい者も健常者も誰でも乗ることができる
そんなモビリティにしたい
それを実現することで
真のバリアフリーを実現する
そんなモビリティにしたいと思いました
ただし 健常者が思わず
「乗ってみたい」
そう思ってくれるようにするためには
何が必要か考えた結果
まずかっこよくあること
そして 足よりも便利であること
さらに楽しいこと
これが重要だと考えました
質問です
このエグゾホイール
「格好悪い」と思われる方
手をあげてください
えーっ ちょっと多い
（笑）
まあ であれば 大体 —
ただですね 今何人かの方
手あげていただきましたが
大体 80%くらいの方が
「超かっこいい」そう言ってくれる
モビリティに仕上がりました
（笑）
はい ただ このエグゾホイール
かっこいいだけじゃあないんです
通常 このような車椅子型モビリティ
こんなスティック型の
コントローラーを使って操縦します
なので 片手はいつも
操縦に専念しなくちゃいけません
そうすると 操縦中に自由に使える手
片方の手だけになります
一方 エグゾホイールは体の姿勢
傾きで操縦をすることができます
そのため 健常者が何気なく行っている
例えば
「両手に物を持って移動する」ですとか
「片手に物を持ってドアを開ける」
こんな動きを 当たり前のように
実現することができます
また もう１つ このエクゾホイール
大きな特徴があります
それは スポーツモードに変形することで
スポーツができるということです
スキーのような動きで
高速に素早く動き回ることができます
両手が自由に使え
素早く動けますので
このように インラインホッケー
ラクロス バスケットボールなど
数々のスポーツを楽しむことができます
いつの日か健常者と障がい者が
同じものを使って 同じルールで
日常生活もスポーツも楽しむことができる
そんなモビリティにしていきたいと
考えています
最後にこのスポーツという観点で
もう１つ ひみつ道具をご紹介します
よく「高度に発達した科学は魔法と
見分けがつかない」ということが言われます
ただ この言葉
「高度に発達した科学は 結果として
たまたま なんとなく魔法のように見える」
ちょっと消極的な感じがします
なので私たちは もっとこれをアクティブに
魔法の世界を科学と技術で実装し
それをスポーツの世界に持ち込みたい
そう考えました
私たちが実装しようとした魔法の世界
それはこちらです
わかりますか？
映画『ハリーポッター』の中で
大人気のスポーツ「クィディッチ」です
このクィディッチができたら
どんなに楽しいだろう
そう思い 私たちは
このクィディッチを
実際にプレイできるシステム
「Ext-Broom（エクストブルーム）」
を開発しています
クィディッチをプレイするのに
一番最初に必要なのは
もちろん このほうきです
それでは早速 登場して
もらいましょう どうぞ
（どよめき）
プレイヤーは彼 坂本君のように
インラインスケートを履いて
ほうき型モビリティに跨がります
アクセル操作 ブレーキ操作は
手元のセンサーで直感的に行うことができます
慣れるとこのように
自由自在に動き回ることができます
ちなみに このほうき型モビリティ
彼 坂本君が電子回路・制御を担当してます
こんな顔してますけど
モデルじゃないです
ちゃんと一流のエンジニアです
そしてですね
このクィディッチをプレイするために
もう一つ必要なもの これですね
「スニッチ」と言われる魔法道具です
人から逃げ回る
まあちょっと 厄介なボールですね
これを私たちは
ドローンを使って実現しました
このドローンには カメラがついており
プレイヤーを認識し
自由に逃げ回ることができます
これの他に
これでやっとクィディッチが
プレイできる思いきや
スポーツの世界には
まだもうちょっと大切なものがあります
何か？
分かりますか？
（笑）
ライバルですね
なので私たちは
この ほうき型モビリティ
コストを抑えて簡単に作れるようにし
量産することができるようになりました
どうぞ
ご紹介しましょう
彼 小林君はこのほうき型モビリティの
メカ設計 デザイン
そして先ほど出てきたエグゾホイール
それも担当しています
ところがですね 彼 つい先日まで
このほうき型モビリティ
乗ることができませんでした
（笑）
何でか 分かりますか？
まあ 運動神経ですね
（笑）
で ところがですね
今日のためにたくさん練習して
このように ちょっと
同じ動きしかできませんが
（笑）
なんとかね 乗れるように
なってくれました
（拍手）（笑）
はい このエクストブルームですね
この後 ほんの少しの時間ではありますが
体験していただくことができます
で すごく面白いものになりましたので
是非 外で体験していただければと思います
オーケー ありがとう
（笑）
ありがとう
（拍手）
さて 今日ご紹介した
これらのひみつ道具
これらは全部
販売を目的としたものではありません
じゃあ 何で作るのか？
私たちにとって ものづくりとは
手段であると同時に目的でもあります
実際に自分たちで考えたものを作り 試し
色んな人に体験してもらって
そこから新しい学びを得て
それを次のものづくりに
フィードバックする
それはものすごく楽しくて刺激的で
かけがえのない体験です
人の歴史はものづくりと共にありました
その結果を消費してるのが
今の私たちだと 私は思ってます
今度は私たちの番です
今日では 知識がなくとも
アプリを簡単に作ることができます
どんなに不器用でも
自動で精密な工作を行うことができます
作り方に見当がつかなくても
キーボードを少し叩けば
先人たちの素晴らしい知見
そして仲間を見つけることができます
ものづくりは人と人をつなげて
新しい可能性を生み出します
皆さんの中から たくさんのひみつ道具が
生まれることを心から願っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）